[Music]
hi i'm rio
i'm the owner of kim's champion repair
and also i'm running on youtube channel
repair studio
today i'm doing a restoration on a pair
of gucci ace sneakers
that retail for around 680 dollars
these issues were brought by one of my
clients unfortunately
they were not maintained well there are
three main things to be restored
first of all the rubber stores are
stained so they
need to be removed second leather upper
gets
scuffed so they need to be re painted
and be finished
lastly metallic painter at the back
is faded so it needs to be retouched
[Music]
i'm taking off the shoe races and
insource from the shoes
[Music]
now i'm using a toothbrush to remove the
dust
from the inside of the shoes before
cleaning
because this dust or sand can cause some
scratches on leather
while i'm cleaning
i'm using a leather cleaner with a soft
hair brush
and gently moving the brush in a
circular motion to clean
the interior and exterior of the shoes
[Music]
now i'm wiping off the foam and water
quickly
to avoid any water damage
[Music]
[Music]
the rubber swords are dirty and stained
so i'm brushing them to clean out the
dirt
first and using a thinner scrubbing
off the stain with leg
metallic green panel is originally made
of leather
and printed with a metallic snake skin
shape
layer when people try to wear the shoes
they tend to touch or and bend the heel
area
i'm using a leather glue with on oil to
glue the peeled metallic back on
it's very hard to find the exactly same
paint color
to match the green metallic planner
since it's not
even one solid color i have to mix
several
paint colors to make the light and shade
of metallic painter
[Music]
the exterior of the shoes are scuffed
and discolored some areas
so i'm using a leather paint to touch up
the scuffed area first
and applying evenly all over the shoes
i'm using a matte finisher to protect
the paint
from peeling off or cracks
shoe races are not clean over like the
original condition
so i'm replacing with the new ones
now i'm applying shoe deodolizer to
eliminate
odor and keep fresh
[Music]
i'm very excited for my client to see
this installation
you